bonjour
alors il me faudrait un rosbif dans le
filet vous avez ça pour
12 mais bon il y a des bons mangeurs
mettez-moi pour 15 mois d'accord
je vais demander à ma femme quand même
je serai plus tranquille comment ça ils
viennent pas oh là là mais tu aurais dû
m'appeler plus tôt là je suis chier le
boucher là il vient de couper le rosbif
c'est pour combien là
on peut ici il faut entier on peut
toujours
elle dit que 6 alors on fait quoi alors
4 4 pour 4 personnes
monsieur avec avec trois tu lui as fait
couper un rosbif pour 10 personnes en
trois attends mais le prend pas sur ce
ton écoute tu fais ce que tu veux alors
oui ben voilà tu bouffes avec tes
parents c'est très très bien ouais c'est
ça ouais allez ciao bon bah je suis
désolé
je vais prendre pour moi là parce que je
suis tout seul
du jambon vous savez
allez-y
il y en a combien là
je veux celle-là celle que vous avez
dans la main c'est là non non seulement
la dernière
[Musique]
des endives au jambon
je vous la compte 120
discuter on va pas chipoter d'accord
prenez les chèques
[Musique]